Unknown: Take a day to this day of your dime. How are you all?
Alright, thank you once again for the CO creation of the interaction. It is always a great gift to us to interact with each and every one of you.
Let us begin this transmission this night of your time by reminding you of the title midnight under the hunter's moon. What does this mean? I will tell you, Thank you
Now
many of you have from time to time
Come to us and said,
I am ready to meet you face to face,
when your ship and I will be there.
And we have done this three times. And in every case as soon as they detected our presence, the ship getting closer and closer our energy building and building, they all ram
simply because
our vibration is very different than yours.
It is much faster than yours.
And in approaching your physical form our vibration at this point
in your society at this time in your evolution
triggers your physical body's survival mechanism because you feel that what is approaching is so different so alien from you
that you go into
Fight or Flight,
mostly flight.
The idea simply is that that part hasn't been fully integrated sufficiently
to withstand the difference in frequency between your physical form and our form, but it is changing. It is getting closer. The more that you apply the information that we share with you, the more you use what we have euphemistically referred to as an instruction manual for the nature and structure of reality, the closer to our vibration, you'll become,
we can to some degree, lower our frequency to make us more compatible with you, but we cannot lower it that far. So in order for us to eventually meet face to face, you must meet us at least halfway.
Now, this is changing as we said over time, and what I'm about to tell you is not
Repeat not
because we don't want to hear the rumors, Bashar said the spaceships are going to land and we're all going to meet them on this day at this place. And this time, that's not what we're saying. But what we are allowed to do now things have changed sufficiently so that we can give you something a little bit closer to the idea.
And what that means is we can tell you now, a particular place a particular date, a particular time, when there will be a lot of heightened activity of what you call UFO spacecraft, extra dimensional extraterrestrial activity in a certain area, for a variety of reasons, we won't necessarily go deeply into at the moment, but nevertheless, by being in that area at that time,
it will be advantageous for the vibrational energy of your being to be open to whatever it is that does happen in
Those moments to whatever it is you might see in that moment, and it will go towards lifting your vibration a little bit closer to the point where we can, along with other extraterrestrials someday meet you face to face. Those of us that have faces that is of course, for there are many that are extra dimensional beings that do not necessarily have the same kind of form that you do.
Nevertheless,
the idea is that there are certain moons months, as you call them, that have been given names by indigenous people in your area for a long, long time.
And the idea of the fall, hunt, the autumnal hunt for the gathering and storage of food for the winter, falls in your month of October
and therefore in
called the next full moon, the hunter's moon.
Your next full moon falls this coming Sunday Next, the 13th.
Therefore, if you are willing, if you are open, it's up to you.
If you will allow yourselves to be in the area called Joshua Tree National Park
on the 13th of October, at midnight, under the hunter's Full Moon, there will be a lot of activity in that area of a variety of types. So you may get a chance to have a higher probability of experiencing something, seeing something, encountering something in a certain way that will help to make you more familiar with the idea of the vibrations of higher realities. You may receive information
You may receive a heightened sense and experience of synchronicity in that place at that time, it is a very powerful portal and it will be highly active at that time. So, many different kinds of consciousnesses may take advantage of coming through that portal for a variety as I said, have their own reasons, but this is as close right now as we can come to giving you a actual physical location, an actual physical time, an actual physical date for when you can to whatever degree is possible and probable for you now have some form of encounter that will lead to stronger encounters in your future.
Does this excite you?
All right, well, we end others will see how many show up
and that will tell us everything. Remember that we
are always observing and always taking a measurement of when you truly are ready or not ready for additional and expanded ideas of contact. So and I remind you, of course, that the language of physical reality isn't words but actions. So by your actions we will know who is more ready. So we will see, but we invite you at this time, to the degree we are allowed to, to the degree that serves you best to be at that place at that time, midnight, October 13, Joshua Tree National Park
and see what happens. And for those of you that do allow yourselves through synchronicity to experience something that you may not have expected to experience. We also invite you to report back and let us know
what it is you experienced, so that we may help illuminate exactly what it is that happened in your experience, because we can bring more information to you, when you let us know exactly what your experience was. And we may be able to open more doors for you as to how to have even a more expanded experience. Next time we give you a place and the time for this is what will now begin to happen toward the idea of open contact. This is one of the beginning stages is to mention certain activity spots, activity times and see what kind of experiences you have what you're capable of perceiving or not perceiving.
All of it is fine. But then, by reporting back in detail what it was, we can perhaps guide you a little bit more specifically and a little bit more precisely as to how to expand the next such experience.
For the next time, place and date that we will give you make sense. All right. So now this begins to become a little bit more interactive. Just another step. It may seem to be a baby step, but babies do grow up. So
we thank you for allowing us to impart this particular information to you.
We bid you a very exciting time for those who choose to go.
And we look forward to speaking with you about your experiences afterwards. And in return for the gift you have given to us, how may now we serve you. You may begin with your questions and dialogues if you wish.
The day we shot Andrew, you Good day. So last time we spoke, you gave me some good insight on following my highest joy how to consistently do that.
You mentioned something that caught my attention, several things. But you mentioned contracts, contracts contracts with other individuals, yes, and how they affect outcomes.
Specifically, how you all participate in an orchestration is what we're saying. That's it. So, how much influence do I have in those contracts
with other people, depends on what you mean by influence in the way that most people on your planet use that word. You have none. However, in having an agreement and an orchestration, because others have also agreed to allow you to experience influence and allow themselves to experience the influence of you, that they are creating for themselves, even as you are creating influence within your own reality. Then you have
Every every kind of influence, but it's again by agreement influence in no way shape or form implies that it is without the idea of matching frequencies through agreement. Okay, got it. The frequencies that I give off or give out.
Yeah, yes. Those changing always? And do I have control over that? Well, in a sense you do. But it's not like you have to actually control the number. The idea is to simply follow the formula and it will automatically adjust because remember, one of the tools in the kit is the organizing principle of synchronous, right. Therefore, by simply following the formula, the frequency is automatically adjusted to meet the occasion. Okay, why would it be otherwise? If it had to be otherwise? It wouldn't be a complete kit, would it? No, it wouldn't be an automatic guidance system would it? Know? So that makes sense? Yes. Yes, it does. You have to realize these things.
need to be looked at holistically, right? Not as pieces that you're attempting to engineer into place. Okay.
And my other question is, how much of this could I see from the beginning of my incarnation from my soul? It depends depends on your theme. Some individuals may need some foresight about certain things. Most individuals don't need anything as long as they follow the idea of their truth then everything will unfold as it should, whether they see it or not. Okay. So it just depends on the person. Okay, my last question is how much can you see?
That also depends on the contracts and the agreements. We in communicating with all of you will impose upon our consciousness, sort of a filter system. We have to come through the idea of your collective consciousness, your archetypal consciousness, your higher mind, and in a sense, we need to have permission that
Tell you what it is that we're telling you. So what we do is we place filters on our consciousness so that if there is some information that would somehow intervene or disrupt your theme, tell you something that you're not supposed to know right now, by your own choice, then we simply won't have access to that information. It'll just be blank.
When we detach from this experience and go back to our reality, we may know far more than we know when we're coming through this connection. Okay, but coming through this connection, it is tempered by what it is that actually serves you best, not the idea of knowing everything, which would then perhaps allow us to say something that wouldn't necessarily serve you. Right. See, does that help it does anything else? I think that's it.
Yes, what would you suggest? I do throughout my day, as I'm taking care of things
work with other people in contract that don't feel good? Well, first and foremost, you always have to make sure that if something doesn't feel correct for you, you have to make sure through honest self investigation as to whether or not it is truly not your excitement, or whether some belief system within you is dampening the excitement that could be there. Once you are clear that you're not the one dampening the excitement, then you can recognize that it may truly not be your preference. And you can make choices and decisions to do the things that are at whatever pace you're comfortable with. But you have to honor your belief system because if you have a belief system that says leaving the thing you're doing even if it's not your excitement is the only thing you believe will really support you in life, then it won't really do you any service to leave it until you yourself are certain. By testing it out by giving yourself a chance to act on your excitement and letting it prove to you it can support you at whatever rate you're comfortable with. Then you can make the show
shift in a way that works for you. Does that make sense? It does. Does that help? It does. Thank you. You're welcome.
Hello, Andrea, good day.
I'm wondering what role
excuse me
What role to plant medicines like Ayahuasca, magic mushrooms a Boga having the evolution of human consciousness. The idea is that they are teachers given to you by the earth to help you get familiar with the concept of being in altered states that allow you to see and experience more of your consciousness on a higher dimensional levels. But the idea of the teachers is to give you a chance to practice what
That state of being feels like so that eventually you can create that state of being yourself without the teachers.
That plays a very important part in your evolution of innocence, upgrading your frequency,
would you recommend
ingesting some plant medicine, I don't recommend anything. If it's your path and your true excitement, and it is a natural teacher of the earth, then by all means follow your path. But the idea, again, is to pay attention to the moment when the teacher is letting you know that you don't necessarily need the teacher anymore. Now, the idea of creating the state on your own. What you're doing, in a sense, anyway, is that if you go beyond that, and believe that you still need the teacher, then the teacher has become a crutch and then you start devolving instead of evolving. But the idea is that when you create the vibration yourself, it may not
necessarily feel the same way that it did when you actually were utilizing the teacher itself, the plant medicine itself, but that doesn't matter, because you will be different. And therefore the state of being will feel different. And it will be for the purpose that you are applying it. So the situation will make a difference as well as to how you feel that vibration but here's the secret.
Remember the principle of physics, you cannot experience something you're not the vibration of first. Do you understand that concept before we continue? Yes. Alright. So
anytime that you remember having an experience of those altered states, you are having an experience of that altered state. It again may not feel identical. But here's the deeper secret
because you cannot
experience something that you are not the frequency of first.
The trick is, you can't even have the memory of having had the experience of an altered state, unless you're in the altered state first, in order to have the memory.
That that's the trick. So as soon as you remember having been in the altered state, you're in the altered state, already, in order to have had the memory of having been in an altered state.
Do you understand what we're saying? Yes. So, then you can learn that you have the ability to do that yourself and act in your life on your passion from that state. Because what you have discovered in your experience with the teachers, eventually
assumingly is the altered state or series of altered states that represents your particular signature frequency in any given situation. And when you
align with that signature frequency of your true self and act from that state, then you are truly in alignment with the flow of the cosmos of existence. Yes, yes. So, does that answer your question? Yes. Yes. It was really good. Thank you. You're welcome. Is there anything else? I was going to ask? The what I said about recommending but like you said, you don't recommend anything? Well, because everyone is different. Well, just for the 13th.
Well, do you do you think plant medicines, what has that's up to you? Okay.
Completely. Totally. Up to you. Yes, thank you very much. You're welcome.
Greetings, Bashar, how do you good day? We are so honored to have you here. So thank you for your wisdom. And we are deeply appreciative of your co creation of this interaction.
So I actually practice healing here in Los Angeles. And I use a number of modalities, and I'm wondering what the best modality might be, in your opinion, best to continue anchoring in new energy for the ascension and new earth. Is there a certain line of codes or modality that we can integrate into our own practices here? Absolutely. The one that works best for you. I thought you might say that well, how psychic Oh yeah.
You do understand Of course, just to check
That a healer never heals anyone directly? Yes, you set up a vibrational frequency, that if the person requiring the healing chooses to match, then they will heal themselves. That's how it works. So whatever modality, which is another way of saying whatever permission slip, you're attracted to us, to give yourself permission to be more of yourself is entirely based on what you're attracted to us. And if you're attracted to use it, that's your first clue that at that particular moment, that least, that's the best modality for you. At that moment, when you change the modality may change because that one may be the best one for who you are now, in that moment, and it may fluctuate. And that's okay. Follow the fluctuations. That overall is the best modality is to follow the fluctuations and the modalities you're attracted to.
Because it's telling you you're changing and now
This one is more in alignment with your belief system than the one you were using a moment ago. So now use this tool. Now use this tool, now use this tool, they're all permission slips doesn't matter which one you're attracted to. If you're attracted, that means it will work for you at that particular moment. That's why you're attracted to it. Does that make sense? Yes, it does. Is it answering your question?
Well, mostly I was actually thinking, yes. When I thought of that question, that if there's another healing modality that is used outside of our Earth right now that might go well? Yes, of course, of course, you know that you are heading toward the idea of using frequencies, resonances and things like that. And many, many cultures use that. But yes, there are many forms. Now some of the different forms are not anything that you could actually do, because they are innocence, shall we say, lined up with the particular alien species that is using them that you
You don't exactly have the same attributes. You understand? They have different attributes than you may have.
Does that make sense? Yes, it does.
Do you want further clarification?
Yeah.
All right.
I'll give you an example of what we're talking about. There are certain alien cultures that can actually manipulate electromagnetic and gravitational waves. Therefore, they can actually create a complex structure in a sense of vibrational structure of gravity. That will allow someone in that gravitational bubble to allow themselves to go back into their natural state more easily. So it acts kind of as a lubricant for them gravitationally speaking. But they have sensors to be able to pick up on those gravity vibrations, those gravitational waves that you don't have. So it's a helium
modality of a particular culture that you're not necessarily able to duplicate, because you don't have the
mechanisms in your body to do exactly what they're doing. Now, does that make more sense? Are there any mechanisms that we have access to that might be heading in that direction that we can incorporate now? Absolutely. One of the things that will come up even though it might be somewhat specialized in your future, as we see now what is likely and probable in the energy that exists right now that we're sensing, that may come to fruition is each and every one of you have a substance in your sinus cavity is called magnetite that is responsible for the idea of allowing you to have a sense of direction by following the magnetic field lines of your planet. Do you understand it's how many animals navigate? You know what I'm talking about? Yes. All right. You can actually amplify the use of that magnetite in a very specific way. So
Sort of similarly to what we were talking about, about the beings that use gravitational waves, but you can be using the idea of the magnetic field of your planet by allowing a vibration that allows a person coming into your field to pick up on a frequency that allows for amplification of the magnetite, in their sinus cavities that will create in their own electromagnetic field, a stronger alignment with the magnetic field of the planet and therefore a stronger connection to the consciousness of the entire world. That is another healing modality that will become a little bit more common in your planets future.
It's like allowing someone to become more of an accurate compass, pointing to magnetic north, aligning them almost instantaneously, with the use of the electromagnetic fields and the magnetite within your body.
So that's one example.
Does that help? Wow. Yes. Thank you. You're welcome. My next question is about light language actually, how we might be able to use this best I'm seeing that many of my friends are now channeling in similar, you know, ways of for healing and for everybody's best interest. So could you please explain a little bit more is patterns of energy patterns of light that can be read as a language. And sometimes just speaking, it can create a particular frequency that can allow a person to match that frequency and align within themselves within their own light beings. So it can be used in a variety of ways. But in terms of actually delivering information that most people on your planet would understand, it still needs a secondary translation for most of them to get it along with the vibration of the light language itself. Because in a sense
We're doing that right now you're hearing the idea of a verbal translation. But we're also manipulating the channels electromagnetic field to create the symbols we see when we see all of you that we read as a language. And we're giving off that energy. And a light language is being sent to all of you. So it will be absorbed in whatever way shape or form you choose to absorb it. But you're not necessarily hearing it as light language. It's a silent language that is being used in conjunction with a verbal translation that makes sense to your physical mind, so that your physical mind is occupied by listening to the verbal language, and isn't really that aware of the fact that there's a light language bypassing it right into you.
That's how we use the idea of light language. That's what we were trained to do.
But different people can use it in different ways. It's up to your own imagination and what works best for you. Does that help? Yes, very much. So thank you. You're welcome. I have one last question.
Yes. And this one is a little switching gears. I would like to know if you could explain a little bit about soul manipulation or splicing in social manipulation? Well, I'll explain. So,
from what I understand, yeah, we genetically as humans are made up of all sorts of different genetics from across the galaxies. Well, yes, not everywhere, but a nice mix. Yes, variety. So what about our souls? Is it possible to have different species so to speak? I don't I don't know if that's the right word souls, our souls.
The idea of what you're talking about occurs in physical reality, souls, our souls. Now, they can take on different characteristics. Yes, but that doesn't mean they're different species. They're just capable of expressing different characteristics, since they contain in a sense to put it this way.
way, all sorts of probable ways of expressing themselves through the idea of physical reality, but they themselves remain as souls. They're not really a different species, souls or souls, you could say it's like the unfired lay that when experiencing physical reality gets fired into the ceramic spirit that represents that particular personality.
But that experience goes back into the soul, and the soul contains that experience. But nevertheless, even though it can use that to express itself in different ways, it's still the idea of malleable clay. It never loses that malleability and therefore, from that perspective, all souls are the same, because they can all shape shift in whatever way shape or form they wish to. Similarly, does that make sense? Is that like walk ins and walk out? Well walk ins again, most people on your planet very
fashioned and misrepresented understanding of that, but in a sense, yes, because a walk in is not actually a different soul. It is the same soul expressing more of itself. It may take on a different personality, because the soul can express more of the being and the physical reality in which the soul is expressing itself can then open up to express something that appears to be a very different personality. But that's just because the soul has expressed more of itself through that person.
So a walk in isn't a different soul. It's simply the same soul expressing more of itself in a different way.
Does that make sense? It does. Does that help? As certainly, yes. Thank you.
Can I know my personal vibration, please, before I leave at this particular moment? Yes. You're bouncing around between 138 and 148,000 cycles per second. Thank you so much. You're so welcome.
Bashar under you Good day. Thank you so much for this gift. It is our passion and our pleasure. It is mine too. This morning I woke up and my The first thing I said was, I'm going to speak with Bashar today. And here you are. Yes. I have like the feeling and that is what's going to happen. Yes. Um, I have a few questions for you friend.
Like a few months ago, I had a dream. Yeah. Which I know was a contact. I was on a ship and my hybrid children were there. Yeah. And then it been that local like an insect came the mantis Yeah. And he was dressed like Elvis
Presley. Well, just for your entertainment. Yeah. And it was a thought projection. The being wasn't really physically dressed. That's a thought projection that allowed the being to appear to be dressed that way. Oh, yeah. Is I thought it was. Yeah, that he wasn't physically dressed like that. But yes, I thought it was really funny. And he made me actually really comfortable with his present exactly why he did it. Okay, well, excuse me. Exactly why she did it. Oh, it's a girl. More or less, more or less as you would understand that idea. It's a little bit different for their species, but it's close enough. Okay. It's kindness. She's saying I saw a few days ago dancing with light around her. Yes. Okay. Wow.
I didn't really know what to ask about her, but I i've been
Following your advice on following your passion you can yeah and with we know
any people on your planet forget that third part. Now Actually, I don't really feel like I have one passion and I basically have many expressions of passion. Yes. Yeah. So I'm yeah, I don't have like a psycho bland behind one passion. I just enjoying my life. Thank you. And I went to a garden and I was taking pictures of the flowers and an insect came and I was really excited about it. I taking more pictures of his flower, but I had the sun on my face. I couldn't look at the pictures and the camera. So I said it's okay. I will look at them and the car. Yes. And what did you find? And Mantis? Yes, so, in that moment, when I saw the mantis I got I wasn't scared. I was just I had the same energy from my dream. Yeah, and I need
That was the same being and then I said, Okay, I want to know what's going on here.
Like, I know she's here, but I don't know what to ask. This is like, you don't necessarily have to ask anything. Just keep going the way you are. Obviously, you're doing fine. Okay? Because you're opening up to more encounters that will give you more information eventually, but right now, it's just a matter of learning to dance getting used to having that kind of an encounter, and eventually, more information will accompany and Okay, you'll understand the symbology a little bit more. Okay. What, speaking of symbology does Elvis mean to you? I'm fun. I really love his personality and like just entertainment and fun. Is there a particular song that is your favorite? Um, I'm not that good with song names. But yeah, there's really like
I thought asked me to sing it.
Can't
you don't have to say no me tenderly think Get it? Well, then that's a message in and of itself, isn't it? Yes.
Wow. And it's not just about the mantas asking you to love her. It's the Manta suggesting that you love yourself tenderly as well. Okay, but that's the basis of your relationship. Is that love? Okay. All right. So, go deeper into the symbols and what they mean for you when you're given those symbols. And you will have a deeper understanding of what the communication is. Because remember, telepathic communication, especially in dream time, usually comes through in symbolic form. Not always and very rarely, actually in words. Yeah, but the symbols contain information. Okay. Yeah, I think that was interesting because I started searching on the internet my web as a Montes.
And represent one moment. Are you strongly connected also to Hawaii? Yes, I'm dying to go there. Well, I hope you're not dying.
When will you go? I was planning next year. All right. around what time? I'm, I'm running run before the summer time. I believe you people call that spring.
Yeah. All right. I grew up without season. So it's kind of hard for me to know. That's all right. Do you also recognize in the symbol you are given not only the idea of the song, but the strong connection that that individual songs also had to Hawaii? No, look it up. Okay. I will. All right. Wow.
I have another question. Yes.
This happened this week, actually. So I'll be having a lot of scenes last time.
We spoke and you told me I had hybrid children? Yes. I'm, like many contacts have happened in my like sleep time. Yes. And they become very open to that. And the more they happen the more I remember details. Yes. But last week, I kind of woke up in the middle of the night and I knew there was a felt that there was someone in the room. Yes, I get scared. And I told these being like, I'm scared. I know is my reaction. Don't go away. All right, um, let me just stand here. And so at some point, I say, Okay, I don't want to admit that I'm not ready and I know not i'm not going to open my eyes. Because I'm gonna freak out. But please don't go away. Just say let me just absorb the energy and then this been asked me, Do you want me to help you with this? And I say yes. And then he I was on
My
she, okay, so she came, I will say to my back, and I felt like energy on kind of my neck. But I was kind of asleep at this point like in between state but then the energy was so strong that my whole body was shaking, shaking, shaking that was a symptom of higher frequency energy coursing through your system. Yes. Okay. So that's what it was Yes. Because you're not used to it. It's got some resistances within your physical structure to energy of that kind of frequency. And therefore, as that energy moves through your neurological system, it can cause your body to vibrate and shake a little bit until you get used to it and open up the conduits so that the energy can flow more freely and not meet any resistance. Okay? So but you'll get used to it. Okay.
Thank you. You are welcome. And I have a few more questions. Do you? Yes. see about that. Okay. When it's above the nature spirits
in a transmission you call nature social network. You were talking about what we call fade earrings. Yes. And I found out that a failure he was growing outside of my window. How exciting for you. It is very exciting. And the night before I had a dream that one of my hybrid babies Watson was in the garden working. Yes. And then next morning the fate he was there. Yes. And it was growing in like 333. So it was three mushrooms, three mushrooms, three mushrooms. Yeah, anti complaining aside. How exciting. So I was. I want to ask about the energy of that. Nope. Okay.
Just go and experience it. Okay, and see who comes up. Okay. All right. Perfect. That's it.
Thank you.
Hello.
Good day. Oh yeah, there we go. Hi Bashar. I am the curious Coco, aka Luca. Cool All right. And you gave me a home fun work assignment. Yes. And I did it.
I chose to do channel automatic writing. All right. And I had a curious connection that I will describe to you in the way that it came to me even though I recognize it may be symbolic, please do. I received communication from a parallel Earth
version of me. Yes, from a version of Earth where
it was a graze Earth, but she was a human who chose Earth and didn't do sort of like adjustments, I guess, like didn't become a full gray or maybe she is a gray. There were some that remained more human. Yes. And so she told me her name. She showed me two symbols. Yes, a car and t. So I call her car T. And I'll Imagine if
I'm very literal in that way, and, and basically explained to me that on her Earth, they no longer could read. And so she was connecting with me because I'm a writer, amongst other things, and we can tap into you to learn how to read Yes, because she presumed that we had a different kind of intelligence available to us because of the world.
relationship we have with words. Well, yes, a different expression of it. Yes. And so she wanted me to finish a book I've been writing for 16 years. Oh, the 12 dynasties in the unknown world. All right, and how close are you to finishing? closer than ever? And how close months all right month Um, so I just wanted to share that since you gave me some home fun work however that home fun was because I was telling you about an alien dream encounter where they had put a tattoo on me that I asked them to remove? Yes, but the dream like the what the home fun gave me wasn't. Didn't seem to have to do with that. And I know that that's fine. But I was just sort of curious if I'm in a state now where I can know the name of that alien race.
You think it wasn't the cocoa? You said they were typical and drama.
dense Yeah, but not the cocoa aka Luca. Typical. Yes. The tattoo. Yes. were shaped like a words. Words yes symbols sigils Yeah, you described them? I can't but I could tell you the tattoos that are currently on my wrists where that tattoo was in the dream better words, all right, maybe connected. So I have a
fun and curious and deep connection with proto indo European. Yeah. And so I decided to tattoo on my left wrist, our word speak, the proto indo European for speak and the original meaning for speak, which is to speak and on my right hand I tattooed Listen, the proto indo European for listen and the original meaning for Listen, which was to hear. And I chose these words because there's certain words in English even
Though I consider it a fine but bastard language
that have never changed in their intent. These words have, okay?
The original meaning is not to speak, the original meaning is to spell.
Okay, words are spelling, casting spell. Yes, yes, that's the meaning of the sigils. to spell to learn how to use words to create and cast a spell with the reader to engage and invite them deeper into a world they may be unfamiliar with, but knowing as they journey through it, the spells will inform them and give them the empowerment to understand how to live in the world. You have woven with your words. Yes, and
I do experience that frequently through the many kinds of readings that I give and through generally the sort of philosophical guidance I give about Taoism. And I have a question in terms of the sigils in these words and my relationship but before you ask it, okay, understand that
this comes from the counterpart that is asking you to write the book
that because they don't read, Yes, okay. So the sigils are the equivalent for them. Okay. You understand? Yes. And so in a few different read, yes, one moment,
but the cocoa are connected to it, okay? Because there is facilitation going between you the counterpart and the cocoa, aka Luca.
They're forming a tribe there to help strengthen and stabilize the connection for all three, okay, and so does that mean that the central language of this
parallel dimension was helped by the CoCo aka loco, whereas the proto indo European here is anokhi.
closer to that, not exact not precise, but closer to that. Okay, good enough for now. And so my connection with Karthi which is Is that like a complete bogus name? Yes. Okay. Is there a better name? bogus would be better? Okay. All right, just kidding.
One moment
I know this may open up another mystery for you. Okay, but a closer representation even though you are actually close would be Carthage. Interesting. Like our Carthage the place? Yes. Okay. Because there is something there that will tell you something about what's going on here. Okay, well, okay, so on that note, though, yes, in my readings, I've been to
Hold, I have a program to communicate, and that it has to do with symbols. So then Karthi is here to teach me her language while I teach her mine. In a sense, yes, you understand that in many languages on your planet. The symbols that are used in their spelling do also contain vibrational codes. Yes. Can you give me one that I should? Well and one of the primary examples is the Hebrew language. Mm hmm. The idea that there is encoded within the different symbols that represent concepts and letters, a vibrational code that can be unlocked to understand the innate structure of existence, because every single letter in the Hebrew language is actually a shadow projection of one particular shape,
changing its position to create
different letters. If you were to have a light and throw shadows on the wall, the shape being an upward spiral like a ram's horn, you would find that you can turn that one shape in certain configurations to create every single letter in the shadows of the Hebrew alphabet. And thus, it actually unlocks when you speak and spell and sing the vibration of the Hebrew language actually unlocks the coalification directly into your genetics, and allows for the opening of keys that have yet to be opened in your bodies that were originally part of the Anunnaki connection, but many of which have still yet to unlock within your genetic structure is also one of these language. It's an offshoot, but not a complete one. So would you say Hebrew is like the purest sigil? No, it's not the purists. Okay. But really, if you wanted the purest, you would have to go all the way back.
to Atlanta, Mm hmm. But you can find some things that are very close in Sumerian, a Qadian.
Things like that. Okay, because we don't have the Atlantean language. No, not completely enough Anyway, you have bits and pieces and fragments in other cultures.
Okay, so, great. Thank you for that. You're very welcome. And that will be all for now. All right. Thank you. Thank you.
Big Brother be and Good day to you.
I'm grateful for your sharing. Thank you as we are grateful for yours.
So I've been connecting to the 13 a lot. 13 the Council of 13 Yes.
I had an experience in Bali where I was sitting down looking at the beach with my partner. And I had this spontaneous vision of myself, or different version of myself on my knees and more of like a surrender type of pose with two painted stripes on my chest. Yes. And I instantly felt very emotional. And I just had a reactive cry in that moment. And all right, it's been part of a piecing together of what I feel I'm connecting to with the council. And before I go further into that, do you have anything? Well, you're also connecting with, again, a simultaneously existing incarnation in that particular location in what you call the past. Oh, in Bali, yes. That's what I felt right and feeling the innate appreciation, the depth of the connection of the indigenous people, for that location for the sky, for the land for the sea, and the gratitude and appreciation that actually flows from them.
Because they know that all of that flows to them.
I noticed that in the culture in Bali, it's very different than us in the States. Yes. That's beautiful. Thank you. Yes.
Some friends and I are going hunting for the red Crystal Skull Pele, on Hawaii. Oh, have a good time. Yeah, we're really excited about it. And I had this
download in a meditation around the idea that you've revealed some of the locations of the skulls generally, yes. And I had this idea that the in that general location, the skulls may be overlapping ley lines that are within that general area. For me, is the what the Red Skull overlapping any Ley Lines might be. Okay, because the the actual instruction that I got was to use a dowsing rod. All right, as a permission slip. I don't mean to be cryptic, but yes, I do.
Thank you. You're welcome.
You mentioned with the crystal skulls that when you sing to them, we would seem to them and chant and that would draw out information from the skulls. Yes, because you create a certain frequency and the information is embedded in the skulls in those frequencies. So as you go up the scales and create different harmonics information will be released from the skull having been embedded in those frequencies. Yeah. And so with the Red Skull, is there a specific chance by the way? Yes, this is a perfect opportunity to understand the synchronicity of why different musical notes are actually called keys
they unlock things that you know not have
that
so with the Red Skull is there i'm i've also received or thought that there may be specific chance for each skull that's core to the skull of court and for the red for my intuition was well that's going to be a chant that may resonate with
The lower chakras of our body, the Hawaiian war champ, the Hawaiian war chant, yes, no, because it wasn't really, originally a war chant.
It was the idea as you're saying, of the power base of physical reality.
And so you also said, The piecing together of ourselves, the integration of ourselves, will be reflected in our ability to gather skulls. And so
the archetype of eat skull can be a great clue to say, Where is this aspect of myself? Not fully expressed, very powerful, and very, very strong, archetypal permission slip for a lot of people on your planet. And so what is the archetypal energy of Pele?
Well, as I said, the base vibrational power of physical reality, the crucible of life into which things are meant
Id and reform. Yes. Yeah, all you have to do is understand the workings of Pele in the form you express it of a volcano. It melts things down, and when they cool off and re crystallizes into something else, constant transformation, constant breakdown, constant rebuilding.
Awesome, thank you. Yes. I you also mentioned that the dolphins are the quote guardians of the master skull, which we've talked about being off the coast of Florida. Yes, the Atlantean master skull. Yeah. And so my understanding is that we'll find the skull when we are damn good and ready or damn good and ready. And the dolphins will in a sense, lead us to the skull. They will help they will help. Amazing
Yes, my friend found a pyramid what he think believes to be a pyramid in myrin just in Northern California.
It's very mysterious. There's a tribe that goes there during certain Solstice is early. Is there anything you can elaborate on with that site? Oh, no, not my place, not your place. Okay.
I have been inspired to make a physical representation of the trinity of earth that you've mentioned before between us the the SSRC business on the people and serious to create a physical kind of permission slip out of crystal I all means, you know, and
and so I've, I've had these
symbols come to me about two years ago and they were very vivid in my mind and it led to transmission of information that I've been learning from for the past two years, I and I wear it on my my neck now. And I was wondering if you have any information around what part of your neck
I guess right over a little lower than my heart, right in the center. All right. They would also be effective on the back that we
Next, since that's the channeling chakra,
and thus create a direct line through to the heart.
And so from what you're picking up from the symbols, they're an assistant channeling permission. So they are a permission slip where you've created one door, but you haven't created the other door. It has to be able to pass through you. I see. Yes, yeah. So by doing it here, in some way, shape, or form, right, however, it works for you. You will open a conduit.
Wow. And I felt that even just from wearing it the next time I gave a transmission with a group that I'm working with, I was getting about time and I had this profound what felt like unbroken channel for about two to our experience and yes, such rapid energy through going through my body as well get ready if you put the symbol on the back for your head to blow off.
Okay, I'll do what I can to get ready for that. All right.
I feel very connected to Morningstar. I remember the first time you mentioned him, I got very emotional to that connection. Yeah. And a lot of the work that I am doing I feel like I'm working with him in tandem or I don't know if it's a him or it is it is one of the all new. Yeah. Seventh hybrid race. Yeah. And I remember you mentioned that the race will represent passion, power and peace and that energy.
I guess I just wanted to acknowledge that and see if there's these any anything else you could tell us about? The it is not are not the time okay. But it will be eventually. Okay, great. Thank you.
I thank you for sure.